bet you did it I think like at the
talking stage
um a girl
coming up with like so what are we or
where's this guy in like a couple months
in I think that's doing too much
wait no well I disagree with him okay
okay depends how many marks in so how
many months
like um for me I've always said like
four seasons on the road trip
Four Seasons and a road trip yeah that's
how that's how long you kind of need to
that's not that's how long you that's
how long you need to kind of know
someone you know so you talk to a girl
you you do like the situationship thing
for a year if it's going to be a
situationship
um then yeah for a year before you kind
of decide whether you want to lock it
down or not okay roughly what do you
guys think is that uh if if you live
together if if like you if you spend a
lot of time together in each other's
yards and each other's places
um to the point where you borderline
living together than less than a year
maybe six months maybe six months so if
she asks you that at six months is it
doing too much yeah if if we were
spending a lot of time together within
in that six months like sleepovers yeah
so you you mean having sex though not
just no but sleepovers literally
sleeping like waking up with each other
like you know I'm saying seeing seeing
each other's lives and that if it's like
that then six months is okay but if it's
not like that and it's a situationship
where you you don't spend too much time
together like that then yeah you need
you need you need at least a year like
for me I don't really like the phrase
like doing too much and doing them
because as as males I feel sometimes you
have to have a level of like
accountability so we'll say oh we don't
want a girl to have x amount of bodies
whatever it be six seven bodies so in
one hand we're saying this
and then in one hand we're saying when
she wants to take it to the next level r
she's doing too much when she's asking
the question but we full well know if
that she's had x amount of wears
previous to us
we're going to be feeling away I feel
like it it's kind of counterproductive
in a way to say that a female wanting to
know the position that she's in
I feel like it's kind of their rat
because there's so much emphasis on her
body's Rising I think I know what you're
saying it's like you it's like when men
say that they want traditional women but
a traditional woman is not going to be
in a situation except in a situationship
and having premarital sex like if she
actually is traditional so it's like you
you can't you can't really have both
right but I I also think my man's in the
back I think he's just in a city boy
phase you know he'll come around wait no
actually my my question for you because
to me like again as a woman we know we
only have so much time so to me I'm like
if a guy is waiting a year that's a long
time here's the thing if you especially
if you want to get married okay I've
been working hard for a long time
I've built quite a bit
for me to put that on the line for
someone to come in and be in a position
where they could affect that in any way
I have to know that person
for me to let that person in to that
level I have to know that person if I'm
dating that person for a year I believe
with my
decent sense of judgment which I believe
I have after that year I believe I would
have seen enough to say yes or no
if I spend a lot more time with that
person we stay each other stay at each
other's places of residence for let's
say days at a time a week and then and
then a couple days break and so on then
it can be less it can be six months
before I can feel like I re when I feel
like I know you
it's not just that you look good because
that's going to go one day but when I
feel like I know you
and I can trust you
and you've got to remember what we oh
sorry so I'm just curious I just want to
get a raise of hands how long do you
want to talk like situationship Court
however you want to call it a girl
before you make it official so I'm going
to say three months
you're good with three months you're
good with three months okay six months
so six months six months
okay six roughly six okay eight months
eight months and then a year okay so so
I it seems like the most common one it's
like six months I think that was the
most hands I feel like six months is
first because that's when you can that's
I feel like that's an ample amount of
time for you to truly get to know
someone if it was three months it's like
three months goes by that debt and and
like a lot can happen in in three months
but then a lot more can happen in six
months and if you're spending a lot of
time with each other like he said if
you're staying at X's house and she's
staying at your house and like I feel
like you guys can truly get to know one
another but if it's in in the time frame
of three months then you're not gonna
know that person she's not gonna really
know you and it's like I don't feel like
the relationship is it could be
long-lasted because
again you don't know each other I think
it comes down to what you actually mean
by make it official because that some to
to people that's different so for
someone make it official might mean oh
just a relationship or just mutually
sleeping with each other so I mean I'm
exclusively so when I said that I met
like boyfriend girlfriend oh after three
months become yeah yeah yeah yeah three
months is enough for that I think yeah
that's a relationship the reason I feel
like three months because on average if
you look at it like one one day during a
week
one weekend day
over three months that's that's plenty
of time well because I it's like I
understand where the men and the women
are coming from because the woman's
point of view you only have so much time
and so every year of your 20s like that
that's less fertility that you have
every year but from the guy's point of
view you guys are risking more today
than ever before getting married and
committing to women and you get less out
of it so of course you're going to vet
them more yeah but haven't you noticed
that the cultures that talk about having
more and more relationship experience
have the worst marital practices and the
worst of worse rates yes whereas like
there's other cultures where it's like
no there is no relationship experience
you me you're gonna get engaged very
quickly and you'll be married within
three to six months and those those
cultures those marriages do fine so um I
I did want to ask you guys a question by
a show of hands though have you ever met
a woman that you wanted to marry
straight away well just just enjoy ever
ever I've met a woman I've wanted
tomorrow straight away yeah actually
raise up hands
um how long did it take you to know you
wanted to marry her
a week so I'm gonna okay okay I'm gonna
say say within three months
did you know you wanted to marry her
So within okay so so in a way if you
really like the girl you don't need that
much time yeah I did on that like my
thing was I thought I wanted to and that
true colors came out after like six
months so there was a facade there so
you I didn't the person I thought I was
wanted to marry wasn't actually that
person so that's why which is why longer
time which is why we need double that
time yeah I don't I don't knock the time
thing because with time you can make a
more informed decision and I think what
it goes to show as in if you make a
decision which is more informed of time
it benefits the man because time works
in men's favor as opposed to women's
favor and also to add on to that as well
a lot of women have a crazy side and I
feel like in six months she can't hide
her crazy side she's gonna show you her
true colors so that's why I feel like
six months is the perfect amount of time
if it's three months she can hide that
she can act like this girl that you want
because it's all an act but if it's six
months now there's only so long that you
can continue it on four before she ends
up challenge you don't think a woman can
had a crazy side for six months she
could do but if you spend a lot of time
with her then it's harder for her to do
that um I I don't think that there's any
way to go about this risk-free like some
of you guys are just gonna get unlucky
and end up in relationships with psychos
it's the same thing with women they're
like oh every man is a narcissist like
you you just might be unlucky I don't
think there's a hundred percent secure
way to go about any of this guys I don't
think it's gambling sorry sorry gambling
gambling is is not a good thing but if I
was gonna bet on a football match I'd
bet on man united to beat Barnet
I think it actually also comes down to
the kind of dynamic in the relationship
so even if she is crazy if you have an
iron fist it's not going to be that much
of a problem if there is that Dynamic of
utter respect it doesn't matter how
crazy she is she knows she can't come up
to you and start shouting at you or
doing crazy [ __ ] because of the way
you're going to respond so as long as
there is that high level of respect
understanding the man's not gonna take
it you have to just demean yourself and
understand that the man is the man and
you are the woman at the end of the day
so and a man's not going to take it so
if you are in that position doesn't
matter how crazy you are you need to
control yourself otherwise [ __ ] is gonna
happen well then she doesn't get the
benefits as well of being in a
relationship as well if she's constantly
constantly a certain type of way that is
exactly why she doesn't get the benefit
it's like we mentioned the
situationships there's a reason that
you're not wife there's a reason you're
not long-term girlfriend and that is
established by your behavior men don't
talk a lot but we understand that we
watch we watch a lot of your actions and
what you do and that's what we base you
on you might say all of this but we're
watching what you're doing and that will
be at the side in fact are if we're
going to take you seriously or not so
question for them as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible